[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
happy thursday you tapped into the group
chat live in the bleacher report app
presented by
fanduel sportsbook your favorite big
three is back the winter soldier
the falcon and captain america my name
is gabby richards
she is our betting captain america of
course yeah of course i'm the winter
shoulder
g-money's the falcon you're kelly lynn
stewart captain america
aka our betting expert and uh
a gentleman who's bringing the vibious
army in the world
g-money greg ivory welcome to the show
um we keep the chat going 24 7 in the
bleacher report app
just search sports betting and then hit
the community tab
yesterday uh z money 22 um
asked for nba locks and then a krause
came through
donovan mitchell over two and a half
three-pointers
donovan mitchell hit four and he added
41. so salute to you hey krauss
appreciate that
um now that um
now that the madness is over it's been a
minute since we went head-to-head with
the great chuckster
charles barkley so it's time for america
to take on
charles barkley once again in our
favorite segment chuck
versus america it's our favorite because
we win all the time
uh we i mean that's basically why it's
our favorite
yeah uh here are the updated standings
or the standings the last time
we tapped in with the chuckster america
we're ten and two
we are a comfortable four games ahead of
charles barkley sitting at six and six
now coming off an overtime thriller in
phoenix
the suns play the clippers tonight we
asked you on social earlier today who
will score more points
devin booker or kawhi leonard this was
the poll
on twitter earlier and overwhelmingly
you guys are riding with devin booker
to score more than kawhi leonard tonight
in their head-to-head matchup
63 of the vote is with d book
greg booker averages 26. kawhi averages
26.
you average about 26 hoodies given away
per
show who's getting one tonight my dude
that's facts that
cabbie that is facts people in the
comments he's speaking facts so you guys
give me some takes
i'll give you guys comments i mean i'll
give you guys hoodies
but you guys tell me right now right now
we're focusing on devin booker kawhi
leonard who's going to score more points
tonight
get in the comments let me know who
you're riding with i'm hooking up you
guys with some hoodies
kelly you talk to us who are you riding
with devin booker or kawhi leonard
well i hate to break it to 63 percent of
the audience but
bottom line devin booker is off a big
time overtime game i know
he's been balling out he's played great
i like hawaii leonard i think we're
getting some real value here
at plus 122 again no disrespect to deep
book he got me that sun's money line
last night
but i think tonight is the night for
kawhi to shine kawhi leonard plus 122 i
dig it in their last game the last time
the clippers played phoenix
he was only four for 21 and even though
he doesn't say much
like game of thrones the claw remembers
so he's gonna be
he's out to he's out to even the score
and also devin booker better get
all his points in the first three
quarters of the game because the claw is
going to clamp him
in the fourth quarter gimme kawhi
leonard plus 122 in their head-to-head
match-up tonight
g-money like i said booker averages 26
kawhi averages 26 which one of these
dudes are you leaning on
to outscore the other and then where is
our audience in the comments
leaning in this head-to-head matchup
cabbie yes sir
i broke it out so i gotta uh introduce
it to the people in the comments
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
and this
is how you get your hoodies i am in the
comments i am in the comments cabbie
i snoop g says kawhi leonard shout out
to you
i snoop g you are walking away with a
hoodie uh motive
motive eight edge says d book he has the
d
book gift going on right here you guys
can see it uh
yeah there it is d book gif shout out to
you uh motive eight you're walking away
with it
zack martin 34 says kawhi cabbie he's
rocking with you and kelly
uh here we go d rose 0-1 um
i lost it d-ro 0-1 gk mc says d-book
and cabbie uh i think we're going gonna
end it there the comments are jumping
right now
uh they're all over the place as you as
you can see i got two d books and i got
two kawhi leonard so i'm gonna break it
right now i'm gonna break the time
you're the time i'm gonna let you guys
know
we're riding with devin booker man i'm
riding with
riding with evan booker i can't i can't
be on the same side as you guys not not
not this early in the show i gotta ride
with dev booger kathy let me just list
off some numbers okay
all right 45 32
36 and 35. do you know what those points
i mean do you know what those numbers
are i i think i just gave it to you is
his shooting percentage no no no those
are the points scored
in his last four games he's been
absolutely balling why change why is
that going to change the guy yo he just
played an overtime game against the best
team in the nba
last night bro he don't think he's like
he's gonna be tired he's a professional
cabbie he's
he's a professional he he can get his
body ready for another game
he's hot i see him having another good
game today go get some buckets d book
all right well greg listen me and you
kelly betting on the three by two hey
rolling on the strip all falls hey
listen we invented this bet
the three by and fanduel has loves it so
much that we have we offer it on three
by tuesdays
and we offer it on thursdays last week
or last tuesday
both of our three by twos cash take a
look
[Music]
jaylen brown thank you very much for the
three by team salute to you sir let's go
to the late game
tonight we have a rematch of the nba
finals we have the lakers
versus the heat and we also have a
potential second round match up
with the phoenix suns versus the la
clippers which three by two should we
hit g money
i know there's some people in the
comments who have made some money on the
three by two this year
hopefully they're in the comments who do
the people want my dude
cabbie let me ask them hey people in the
comments
who are we riding which game are we
riding are we riding
the lakers versus miami or are we riding
phoenix versus the clippers
which game are we riding you guys let me
know in the comments get give me some
gifts give me some gifts
give me some creative gifts but kelly
can you uh
i mean is there any way you can uh
research or get some data to choose like
how are you choosing this how are you
going to choose it actually
greg this has been the hardest 3x2 i've
ever tried to do
normally i feel like i lean really
heavily towards one side or another
but this one i'm looking at la miami
both are terrible
well excuse me miami is terrible against
the three
la defends the three really well both
neither team is gonna
really pop off too much then the flip
side both phoenix and the clippers
defend the three really well but then
they also both shoot the three really
well
so i kind of told kathy this before the
show to break my tie breaker i'm just
gonna go with the later game that way
you have to put an overtime hour so give
me
phoenix in the comments wow give me a g
money and i don't need to do this to you
i'm not as malicious as kelly i don't
have the same relationship
that you and kelly have but give me
shooters always give me sons
versus clippers the clippers are the
best three-point shooting team in the
nba they shoot at a 42
clip so all we really need is like
pat bev or playoff p to show up and
devin booker
did not hit a three-pointer last night
he went over six
so i feel like he's going to come out
shooting in this game so give me sons
versus clippers in the three by two
g-money which game are you leaning on
leaning towards lakers heat
or sun's clippers cabbie you know i'm a
man of the people
i gotta get into these comments and uh i
gotta figure it out so here we go grace
24 is rocking with the sons he has the
old g sons gift you guys can see it
right there i don't even know who that's
that
that's dan marley my dope my dude
thunder dan marley
that's the year i was born on the back
that's the year i was born
greg moving along i knew i knew you
would know who that was gabby but then
yeah that's the year i was born eight
shut up you know who won hey wait do you
know who won the
the nba championship that year the year
that you were born in 93 i'm gonna go
with
uh uh michael jordan i was gonna say the
chicago bulls
let's go sir like i know they want it a
lot all right here we go let me get back
to hit that let me let me get it back to
the matter at hand i got pretty much
yeah rye rap rise rocking with the miami
heat shout out to you ref rye
big bandito he says phoenix in la come
on
phoenix in la come on he's he's making
his feet
shout out to you he's rocking with jimmy
butler in the heat uh
chris 12 c says sons versus the
laker no no the clippers clippers
actually uh
and i got one more for you cubby i got
one more eli cohen my guy eli
hey i found you eli eli is rocking with
the miami heat
he's rocking with the miami heat and the
lakers so guess what
my guy eli that's my guy i'm rocking
with him we're walking with the miami
eli eli we got to go later in the book
dude to go to the suns and clippers we
got to go to the the second of the
double header now
but look at look at look at look at okay
let why can't we please both of us why
can't we ride the lakers in miami
and then roll it over on the phoenix
versus the clippers
because because kelly and i don't think
that the sun's the lakers and the
uh and the heat are going to that first
time
no winnings to take i need bad vibes in
the comments need bad vibes in the
comments right now because cabbie is
pulling it
filling this whole show up with bad
vibes bad vibes cabbie
reasonable vibes reasonable vibes listen
if you like if you like either game make
sure to hit uh the br betting socials
for the link to the to the boost on
fanduel for the 3x2 so
tap in with our rbr socials look people
have been hitting
bombs on these first basket parlays
recently uh we posted this on social
this is just
this is the dream right here um salute
to
you me and dupree who found a glitch in
the matrix
and he hit a four first basket apartment
held
four dollars turned into 10 racks
like that is un salute to you you me and
dupree
i hope you i hope you uh treat the
homies for a nice steak dinner or
something tonight but
uh because you that is expert level
we congratulate you um so who's hitting
the first basket tonight in the suns
versus the clippers game may we please
see the menu
at the top you'll see devin booker who's
coming off a 35-point performance
last night against the utah jazz kawhi
leonard in his last game
29 against portland but what we need is
the first
basket these are long odds they're tasty
odds marcus morris chris paul papette
zubotz down there at plus 1000. um
take a big swing because fanduel is
offering insurance on the first bucket
prop bet for this game so if your first
basket doesn't hit
but your player scores 25 or more
fanduel will refund your first basket
bet
up to 25 on each game
but you have to opt in okay so make sure
to read the terms and conditions
and check out fanduel sportsbook for
more details opt-in please
g-money who's getting it started for the
suns and the clippers tonight
cabbie you know i'm not giving you no
answers before i
check in with the people
i can't you know i gotta check in with
the people hey cabbie actually the
comments are full of bad vibes right now
because uh oh
no the negativity that was thrown i mean
no reasonable advice we know reasonable
scales of justice or something that
i think that promotes reason i think i
don't know what astrological sign that
is with the scale
i'm i'm afraid i'm afraid i see an
astrological sign nothing
but with the scale it's not no all right
all right here we go here we go uh libra
yeah all right
guys i got to focus here i i gotta focus
here all right
uh who who is scoring the first basket
who's scoring the first basket you guys
get in the comments let me know who's
scoring the first basket
that's pretty simple uh kelly is there
any way you can handicap this or is this
just you throwing a dart
i don't think this is like a traditional
handicap of sorts right i think you need
to play it out in your mind okay
we've got phoenix suns on the road after
playing last night
maybe they won't be fatigued till the
second half maybe they start out slow
and then pick up the pace it's tough
you gotta figure out who's gonna win the
tip okay let's just say
phoenix gets lucky even though they only
hit 47 percent of their tips on the road
they get the ball first
they dribble it down de-book maybe
goes for that three that cabbie said
misses
chris paul gets the rebound you know the
guy that makes every single nba team
he's on
better i don't know this is hard i i've
hit
tons of first touchdown scores but first
basket is rough
for me so i'm just gonna go with some
guy not at the top of the list and
that's mr chris paul
the guy who should be in the mvp
conversation plus 9 15.
that was elaborate and i yeah i lost you
but then i found you again
on the chris paul uh rebound so chris
paul i'm on the other side with uh with
kawhi leonard
in the past few games marcus morris has
gotten it started
for the clippers but for some reason i
think it's the claw i think it's kawhi's
kawaii's turn to get it started uh for
the clipper so give me that i believe it
was at plus 500 from fanduel
give me the club g-money who do you like
to score the first basket in the suns
and clippers
cavs i actually don't dislike that but
you know once again man of the people
i'm back into the comments and i'm
rocking what's squad here we go we got
bulls 49ers says paul george shout out
to you bulls 49ers you are walking away
with a hoodie matt dodgers in the
comments
mad dog dodger ahmed he said uh
he i think he says glennard i think he
says the
uh kawhi leonard so shout out to you
matt dodger you're walking over to the
zac
schema zack skeemo says devin booker
says devin booker shout out to you
uh zach uh rip melo
don't really like the username but that
is okay here we go eight deandre ayton
d'andre ayton is who he's rocking with i
like that too all right here we go
uh little pitch little pit says d book
all right everybody i said you're
walking away with a hoodie
hey says kawhi all right that's it
everybody i said you were walking over
lady all right this is how it's gonna go
down
you know what kelly was talking about it
sounded familiar because
we usually rehearse before the show and
i went through my whole
giving away family secrets and how i was
gonna
explain how you know the first basket
was gonna be scored
but kelly just went and took what i was
gonna say but let's
show let me let me tell you guys how
it's really going to go down all right
here we go
we got the tip we're going to ayton's
going to win the tip he's more athletic
cabbie kelly they've been saying it's
the phoenix suns are tired
they have tired legs because they played
an overtime game last night so i see
them
uh missing the first shot clippers grab
the rebound push it up
pg swing it around kawhi touches the
ball a little bit
gets it back to pg pg puts up the three
right
he puts up the three he misses he
misses guess who come cleans it up
cabbie
big man morris marcus morris no zubots
give me zuma rebound put it back
yes plus 1 000 i'm taking it baby i am
taking it
okay uh if you didn't get a hoodie when
greg just gave away 14 just now
uh don't fret you can drop your take in
the sports betting community stream in
the br app we give away hoodies there
every day but you he g-money's still
going to give away some more hoodies
because the show's not over yet
uh after a highly contentious season
kelly tried her hand at the same game
parlay offered by
fanduel and she experienced how insanely
difficult it is let's take a look at
this
it's 55 to 1. yeah you did take a long
shot
it wasn't very it was a long shot my
teamer should be 22-1
i know i have to repeat this every
single week but let's see what nonsense
we can show we can show my
two out of five tickets yeah whatever
let's pull it up let's see what greg's
got
i just want to let you guys know this is
this is our expert here that's only
getting two
out of five well the point didn't win
gordon hayward got hurt
devonte graham had five what do you want
from me under
like i said absolute money pj washington
the one that cabbie didn't even like
no sweat on the right now hey everybody
in the comments
everybody in the comments let's clap it
up for two out of five for kelly
this is our expert here two out of five
shout out to you kelly shout out to you
hey it's it's harder
can we get harder whichever minus 190
harder greg's
i just want to make it known usually i
go like three
four five four four five yeah when
you're okay
our expert players
let me break it down for everybody who
doesn't live in a fanduel area i want
you to download the fanduel app you can
still look at everything i want you to
click
same game parlay you can bet someone to
have
two rebounds at minus 850.
like this is the kind of nonsense that
greg is picking every single week
of course kawhi leonard is going to have
two assists tonight
sure please ty go ahead greg i want to
hear who you got this week every uh no
no everyone's got
a pgp
oh oh cabbie are we getting a lot
they're all clapping for kelly because
she went two out of five
clap it back up man good job hold on i
really appreciate you guys
hey for for the record g-money at the
start of this season
you did you were you did come out with
the vibes are like it is going to be
easy to hit the same game parlay that's
why you bet kelly 500 bucks
originally yeah absolutely and you had
to like
ask greg ask greg how it went mom no day
when he was the mullet over nine
easy money timmy
didn't even reply to me he sent me a
video that was great
i paid i paid you uh i paid you
immediately
shout out shout out to you kelly shout
out to you uh i didn't gripe about it
either i just actually just gave you
your money but anyway
hold on hold on hold on let me just part
two points
let me just take the audience behind the
curtain a little bit did you
lose the 500 that you won from kelly on
that zags
that zags game no i only lost back 200.
no i only lost like 200.
okay all right it's but but captain i'm
thinking more it's okay
it is okay because kelly's gonna owe me
another 500 with well the nets bet
remember she said the nets aren't going
to finish top four
in the conference they're easy to finish
top four that's right yeah the nets are
actually number one
in the easter easily easily gonna finish
top four so kelly once again i gave you
4.95
uh and 95 cents last week to uh cash out
this week
this week we're going to go up we're
going to just going to take it up a
little bit 497.
76. 4.97 they can't make a run heater
going to get at the w tonight we're
gonna see
we're gonna have a fun six weeks here
4.97 flat you can cash out right now
yeah we have about 22 games left in the
regular season so all these bets will
will be resolved in the next few weeks
greg what do you got what do you have
for us today g buddy
it's so funny the comments are literally
still clapping
the comments are literally still
clapping all right uh here we go
this is let me let me take i guess i
gotta i guess i gotta put the team on my
back again
since our expert only goes two for five
on parlays
here we go let's uh let's pull up the
graphic uh we got dennis schroeder
dennis schroeder
fifth so we're doing lake lakers and
miami tonight
my bad cabbie my bad let me lakers miami
and then we
we're calling this the ds special we're
calling this the ds special because it's
going to be all focused on my guy dennis
schruter
this is ds special right here here we go
so we got dennis shooter
going over 15 points cabbie anything you
have to say about that i like it i like
it listen
he's gonna him and tres are gonna be the
offense for the lakers cause there's
kyle kuzma is questionable there's no
brawn there's no a.d and there's no tail
and
horton tucker so it's schroeder's game
bro all right all right yup yup yup
shout out to cabbie for signing off on
that one appreciate you brother all
right here we go
moving on with my guy dennis uh we gotta
we're gonna go with
four assists just go just he's a point
guard minus four dollars
he's a point guard i like it i like it
get get caruso out on the on the break
a nice little little alley-oop to the
carru show a few times
yeah yeah go get four and then uh cabbie
go get four rebounds dennis go get four
hey listen hold on hold on andre
drummond
is playing tonight and i don't know if
his toenail has grown back
but he he's available on his right big
toe he's available to
he's he's gonna swallow like for eight
to ten twelve rebounds
however you know cabbie i just had to
pull up the fanduel app just so you know
dennis schroeder over forces kelly is a
minus
900. goes kelly
everybody
nonsense like everybody's still clapping
in the comments everybody
i've shot vegas greg over here come on
everybody clap it up
this is a vegas greg move this is a
vegas greg parlay
right now if they're all minus 900. hey
vegas greg
you guys let it happen organically just
let come on just let it happen
okay four rebounds we're moving on
we're moving on then we're gonna go
dennis shooters oneplus made
three-pointers kelly go look it up and
tell the people how much that was
minus five eight we know you want to we
know you minus
580. yep exactly this is gonna come
this is gonna be a minus 400 tickets and
then and then here we go we're gonna
we're gonna round it off since we're
rocking with my guy
dennis schruter and uh he's gonna have a
good game today that's basically what
we're saying
we're gonna rock with the lakers plus
nine let's rock with the lakers plus
nine that's really optimistic the parlay
that's real optimistic bro come on i
will say the lakers are without
the heat of an absolute trash against
the spread in american airlines arena i
will say that
i lean towards lakers plus nine but what
i do like
is the under tonight so hopefully that
means
lots of defense so you know dennis
shooter scores
i don't know 12. no
actually actually you know what that
means kelly since you like the under
that means it's going over so everybody
in the comments
you guys know what to do pet that over
baby
[Laughter]
okay so let's see the ticket let's see
the ticket
pull up the ticket man pull up the
ticket so let's tell you thank you go
ahead kelly go ahead go
let's go fine just go good god
what do you want me to say i just say
the same thing every single week this is
a travesty
you are you are trying to find a glitch
in the matrix bro if this doesn't hit i
feel like
you should you should send kelly that
219. that's how we should do it
if these easy ones don't hit you should
send her the winnings
the winnings that you would have gotten
to kelly on venmo or cash app whatever
you guys
i mean if she would have if she would
have went three for five in her parlay
last week
maybe i would have considered it but two
for five isn't cut me cabbie no i'm not
no no all of my stuff was like plus 400
plus
280. i've been there before kelly and i
went three and five doing that i've been
there before
okay so keep laying on that chalk all
right you still are not even on the
season
even after you hit the one part like
you're not even on the season is one for
14 1 and 14.
vegas greg you cannot make money betting
like this
all right here we go thank you everyone
do you want you want to give away a
couple more hitties do you money or yeah
yeah yeah
yes i'd like to give away a hoodie
because i got in trouble for this
on the ask me anything on friday can
someone send finn sanity five
a hoodie please you guys making me look
bad okay vincent
what is he getting a hoodie for for last
week because he put
he was the only one that put vegas greg
in the comments
[Laughter]
no he's not getting a hoodie no no
anyway we're in the comments giving away
hoodies
uh shimmy burger salty kelly at its
finest yes she is very salty shout out
to you you're walking away with me here
we go j
quinn 24 wow schroeder over everything
shout out to you g quinn i mean
obviously you see we are rocking with
schroeder uh johnny ball game 77 says
fade kells
huh i don't know if you're gonna win a
lot of money on that but maybe you will
yeah anyway here we go friendly jowl
friendly joe says i don't know about
that i don't know what you don't know
about
friendly jail but guess what i know you
were walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go kobe white kobe white the
giant says vegas kelly
let's hear what you have uh kelly i
don't yeah she
yeah i don't know and you're walking
away yeah here we go one more one more
one more semdog05 stop arguing with greg
the goat
shout out to you brother you're a goat
as well
shout out to you that's how you
guarantee yourself a hoodie
right there well done hold on homie
thank you so much for tapping into the
group chat remember what you learned
here today
right in the middle of your screen vegas
greg
uh also it's swing for the fences
on those first basket tickets those
first basket parlays
lastly old habits die hard and uh
parlays keep the gratification away so
good luck
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
or
vegas greg my name is cabbie richard
we're leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign